uh
right hello um the
members have the hearing panel have now
made their decision and
when i when i've had confirmation that
we're live streaming i'll hand over to
the chairman to announce the decision
okay i've had now had confirmation that
we're live streaming so
over to you chairman thank you thank you
tris and
uh sorry for the long delay quite a lot
to debate on this
um however having considered evidence
from all parties
we have agreed the variation in part
to allow the supply of alcohol and
regulated entertainment from 7 am
in respect of the application to vary
the terminal hours
is refused in respect of the supply of
alcohol
however we are happy with late night
refreshment
and regulated of entertainment until 12
30 on a friday
and 1 pm on a saturday on reaching our
decision we
have taken into account the risk the
impact on those in the locality and the
risk to public nuisance and noise
perhaps to look perhaps the applicant to
look at applying for a tens license
procedure and further down the line
um in the future so that could be
obviously done
um a full decision will be made within
five working days and sent to all
interested parties so i thank you for
your indulgence
and sorry that we've kept you so long
thank you chairman and that's now the um
close of the meeting
yes yeah thank you thank you very much
indeed